- The Royal Albert Hall
is one of the most famous
and prestigious concert halls
in Britain and the world.
It's 150 years old,
and basically every world famous musician
and band has performed here at some point.
The trouble is, the science of acoustics
wasn't really well developed
back in the 19th century.
A tall, oval-shaped auditorium
with a domed glass roof,
well, it looked impressive and regal,
but it created an accidental echo chamber,
the exact opposite of the focused sound
that you'd want for a concert.
Beautiful location, terrible sound.
To see how they fixed it,
we need to go up,
to the parts that the
public aren't allowed into.
- It was constructed without any thoughts
of acoustics, really,
but it was also glazed,
it was daylit, naturally lit.
The Prince of Wales who
became King Edward VII
made a speech there at the public opening.
Everyone heard his voice twice.
So immediately they had to do something
to solve the acoustics,
and they installed what's
called a calico velarium,
it's like a sail cloth hung from the roof.
It was partially successful,
the inner-glazed roof
suffered from leakage,
broken glass panes as a result
of the Second World War,
and also daylight really wasn't
suitable for a modern hall.
The inner glazing of the dome was
removed and replaced in 1949
by an aluminium velarium,
which is what you see there now.
In the late 1960s, the now-iconic
"mushrooms" were added to the hall.
They are suspended, convex diffusers,
and they help cut down
the echo tremendously.
In 2019, the sound system
was replaced completely
within the hall, and
the subjective response,
the reaction from audiences,
has been absolutely tremendous.
- This is right at the top of the hall.
That is the glass roof, it is
40 meters down to the floor,
and just through there is an
air vent called the "corona",
and running across it
is a tension steel mesh
to let the technicians access it.
I am assured by the team
here that it is fail-safe
and I can walk on it.
Guy, hello!
- Hello, welcome to the corona.
- Oh, it's a lot cooler in here.
[laughing] Must be...
oh, I looked down!
[laughing] I should not have looked down.
I mean, you're health and
safety officer here, right?
- That's right, yeah.
- You're just casually
standing on the mesh?
- Mm-hm. Yep.
Feel free to step out with me.
- That's a full fear
response from me, that.
I was going to say, is there
anything I can grab onto?
I was going to-
- That's very greasy.
So most people hold my hand.
Including the fire brigade!
- [laughing] I was going to ask,
like, who has to come out here?
Oh my god, it bounces. It bounces.
Who has to come out here?
- Technicians, people who need
to put shows on and rigging.
- Haah, ha-haah. Putting all
my weight on that foot
is so, so difficult, bloody hell.
Oh my god, don't bounce!
- The weight of the
Royal Albert Hall roof,
the dead weight of the wrought-iron
structure is about 340 tonnes.
The roof itself in total can take
about a thousand tonnes,
inclusive of all permanent and imposed loads,
such as wind and snow loading.
There is approximately a
hundred motorized chain hoists
which hang from the original
wrought iron structure of the roof,
which vary in their load rating,
but some can carry up to 1-2 tonnes
of show infrastructure.
We have lighting rails,
which support lighting,
sound speakers, as well as
the mushrooms
which provide the acoustic
dampening of the auditorium.
The mushrooms, despite their
quite substantial size,
only weight around 40kg.
All of the mushrooms,
show infrastructure, speakers,
is all hung from the original
wrought iron roof structure.
- I am not sure I can move right now.
I'm genuinely...
- Just look forward, just
look forward and walk.
Just walk, there's no way you can fall.
There's no way you can fall.
Just walk, look, just look at the pole,
and that's it, you've done it, well done.
- Thing is-
- Congratulations(!)
- Thank you.
I know it's all my head
because the pole is
connected exactly the same
as this grid is.
- So this is the corona, the crown,
and that is the oculus above us.
- It's creaking.
- That's the heat expanding,
so temperatures are regularly
in the thirties and forties.
- Typically, whenever there's
a fall-from-height risk,
the factor of safety on
the material properties
that would go into the design
of the tension wire grid
is 5:1, which means there's a
fivefold weight allowance of the
material property which it can support.
- But the most surprising thing of all
about this roof
is not how they fixed
the acoustics,
it's not this terrifying
technicians' trampoline,
it's just out there,
and the best way to see
that is from the outside.
I'm going to need a hand, I just-
- Feel free.
[Tom gasping]
- The roof was constructed
in full in Manchester
and then it was dismantled
and reassembled in London
through internal scaffold shoring
from the inside of the hall.
Every beam and element of
the wrought iron trusses
was then winched up to the top of the roof
and then assembled in situ.
The shoring was then removed once the roof
had been completed in full
and dropped by about 5/16ths of an inch
or about 8mm, which would've
been a heart stopping moment
I think for all those involved.
- All of which leads to the
most starting thing for me,
the reason I made this
video, this roof,
this iron and glass dome with all that
equipment hanging from it,
it's not actually connected
to the rest of the building.
It's touching, sure,
it's resting just here,
you can see where the two structures meet,
but there's no cement, no
bolts, no attachments at all.
This dome is just so incredibly heavy
that it's not going to move,
and it hasn't for 150 years.
600 tons of iron and glass,
and a load of Victorian engineering.
It doesn't need anything more
because anything powerful
enough to shift this
wouldn't be stopped by a couple of bolts.
The roof of the Royal Albert Hall
isn't actually attached.